This December, Netflix is cooking up a buffet
with a little something for everyone, with
both exciting originals and new blockbusters
like Avengers: Infinity War.
And that's just the beginning.
Here's a quick look at everything good coming
to Netflix in December 2018.
Andy Serkis made a name for himself as the
motion capture juggernaut behind Gollum in
The Lord of the Rings, and he's gone on to
parlay that particular skill into a long run
behind the camera and special effects of some
of the biggest blockbusters of the era.
With Mowgli: Legend of the Jungle, Serkis
will again be heard and not seen as both the
director and the voice of Baloo.
This gritty origin story sees the jungle boy
Mowgli on a quest to discover who he really
is.
Along the way, he'll face down not only the
vicious Sher-Khan, but also perhaps the greatest
threat of all: Humans!
Look for it on December 7th.
On-screen gangster tales have ranged in locale
from old-world Sicily to early 20th-century
London to that most terrifying location of
all, modern-day New Jersey.
But what about Canada, eh?
Well, good news: Bad Blood is storming the
streets of Montreal with a gritty dramatization
of real-life crime boss Vito Rizzuto.
After spending years in prison watching his
hard-won empire fall to pieces before his
eyes, Rizzuto gets released and sets out to
retake his territory and exact revenge on
the competing gangs who killed his son and
father.
Check it out when the first season premieres
on December 7th.
Espionage and political intrigue are the names
of the game in this Australian series that
follows a small group of spies working in
the secretive central Australian base Pine
Gap — a real location.
Pine Gap weaves actual events into its fictional
narrative, blurring the line between high-stakes
drama and real-life consequences.
Although the series already aired in Australia
starting in October 2018, Pine Gap is set
to hit Netflix globally on December 7th with
a first-season run of six episodes.
Don't miss it.
Netflix's musical documentary series ReMastered
is tuning up for its third entry, and if it's
anything like the first two, it's bound to
hit all the right notes.
In Who Killed Jam Master Jay?, audiences will
get an in-depth look at the circumstances
surrounding the unsolved shooting that took
the life of the iconic hip hop DJ in 2007.
Take a look when ReMastered: Who Killed Jam
Master Jay?
Drops on December 7th.
There's a lot to love in this high-stakes
Australian series, which follows two strangers
who accidentally wind up in the middle of
a criminal conspiracy and find themselves
on the run from both the police and the bad
guys.
Wanted packs its airtime with comedy, action,
and drama, and leaves you hungry for more
every time the credits roll.
And with only six episodes in each of the
first two seasons and four in the upcoming
third season you can be sure that not a minute
goes to waste.
You can still catch up on the first two seasons
before the third season shows up on December
13th.
If you haven't clocked in for Cuckoo yet,
now's a good time to start.
The show centers on a proper British couple
whose daughter just spent a year abroad.
When they pick her up from the airport, they're
dismayed to find that she's returned with
her lover a slacker hippie played by Adam
Samberg.
"Well, here he is.”
“Sorry?”
"It’s an honor Ken, just a great great honor.”
After the first season, however, Samberg left
for other projects and was replaced by American-werewolf-in-London
Taylor Lautner for the rest of the series.
Somehow, it all ended up working, and you
can check out the fourth season on December
14th.
"Soon your body will be butchered by extraterrestrial
lasers, but our souls shall remain together
through cuckoo."
With Narcos, Netflix enthralled the world
with the story of DEA agent Steve Murphy and
his partner, Javier Pena, as they worked to
bring down the notorious Pablo Escobar.
Now, Netflix is putting their true-crime touch
on the tale with Inside the Real Narcos.
As the name suggests, this docuseries will
delve into the real-life stories of drug cartels
in Latin America, told through interviews
with real criminals.
It's sure to be an engaging experience, and
you can get your fix when Inside the Real
Narcos drops on December 14th.
English comedian Jimmy Carr hosts this upcoming
comedy panel show, which sees a group of comedians
sitting down to solve some of the social problems
plaguing the world.
Each episode will see a different panel of
comedians tackling a different issue, lending
their trademark wit to possible solutions.
Effective?
Probably not.
But it should be good for a laugh, at the
very least.
Tune in for The Fix on December 14th.
Novelist John Grisham carved out a career
with his numerous best-selling courtroom thrillers,
many of which have in turn been adapted into
blockbuster films.
He's sold more books about judges than the
guy who wrote the Book of Judges.
With his 2006 book The Innocent Man, however,
Grisham took his time-tested formula and turned
it on its head, writing a true-crime account
instead of fiction.
The Netflix adaptation will feature John Grisham
and will dig into the case through a series
of interviews with people who were involved
in the case.
Look for it on December 14th.
Clearly, Netflix has been down under to pick
up a ton of Australian series, but their upcoming
fantasy thriller Tidelands marks the streamer's
first true Australian original show.
Tidelands centers on a criminal who heads
home to a small village on the Australian
coast in pursuit of a quiet life.
But she soon finds that the town is secretly
home to a group of supernatural beings called
Tidelanders.
Dive in on December 14th.
Netflix hasn't been shy about showing off
their upcoming thriller Bird Box, and for
good reason.
Based on the 2014 book of the same name, Bird
Box stars Sandra Bullock as Malorie, a new
mother whose world is turned topsy turvy when
people begin taking their own lives in bizarre
ways.
It turns out that there's some kind of sinister
force at work — once you see it, you're
driven to madness.
Madness!
With a premiere date of December 21st, Bird
Box's dark vision of the future will be here
just in time for Christmas.
Happy holidays!
"Please don't take my children!"
Netflix's original stand-up releases for December
will be arriving in two parts.
The first, Vir Das: Losing It, debuts on the
11th and marks the Indian comedian's second
special on the service.
Das told Gulf News that the new special will
touch on global events as well as his own
personal life.
The second stand-up special this month sees
talk show host Ellen DeGeneres taking to the
stage for the first time in 15 years with
a comedy set called Relatable.
Take a look when it drops on the 18th.
The holidays are arriving with a bang this
year, as Netflix introduces a handful of high-octane
action favorites.
November sadly saw the removal of Hellboy
II: The Golden Army, but December 1st sees
its predecessor, 2004's Hellboy, showing up.
Also on the first, look out for Terminator
Salvation and the 1985 martial arts flick
The Last Dragon.
On Christmas Day, unwrap Avengers: Infinity
War, the first part of Marvel's epic Phase
Three culmination that has the scrappy Avengers
taking on the big bad Titan Thanos.
You'll also find a brand new selection of
dramatic films landing this month, such as
8 Mile, Meet Joe Black, and Seven Pounds,
all of which arrive on the first.
After that, the 16th offers the chance to
check out Eddie Redmayne before he was Newt
Scamander in The Theory of Everything.
Redmayne stars as Stephen Hawking in this
hard-hitting bio-pic about the acclaimed physicists
early years and his struggles to cope with
the gradual onset of Lou Gehrig's disease.
There's an eclectic mix of comedies hitting
Netflix this December, but they all have one
thing in common: they're hilarious.
"What's the matter David?
Never taken a shortcut before?"
The Friday trilogy hits Netflix on the first,
alongside Shaun of the Dead, The Big Lebowski,
and the Bill Murray-led spy spoof The Man
Who Knew Too Little.
Finally, 'tis the season for blood and mayhem
this Christmas.
The first of the month sees the arrival of
1998's Bride of Chucky, John Carpenter's 1983
adaptation of Stephen King's Christine, and
My Bloody Valentine, that cheesy 3D slasher
from 2009 about people throwing pickaxes at
you.
It'll be easier than ever to binge brand new
shows in the coming month.
On the third, dive into Blue Planet II, the
follow-up to the BBC's critically acclaimed
nature series.
The sixth of the month sees the addition of
the first season of Happy!, an offbeat SyFy
series about a mentally unbalanced hitman
who becomes friends with his daughter's imaginary
unicorn.
Based on the graphic novel by Grant Morrison
and Darick Robertson, Happy! is a visual treat
for anyone looking for a different sort of
comic book hero.